there was a point in time where everyone
was trying to sign you yeah um at the
peak of mmg i know you guys had
conversations like yeah
what was like
were you always just like yo i'm gonna
do with the opm way like i'm you know
like like why did why did you never
really take that bigger step as far as
like
um
never ownership was never on the table
and i always more than anything more
than being a celebrity more than being
super rich all for you know whatever
they could offer me right in any way i
always wanted to be a
ceo you know what i'm saying like i
always wanted to be a ceo i always
thought of myself as a ceo and i always
felt like i was smarter than just what
the microphone and the instrumental
had to offer you know and i and i and my
only thing was it wasn't a fear i had
but i never wanted to just be diminished
like as good as i could be as a rapper
as an artist i never just wanted to just
be that
you know that would have felt like a
failure to me automatically like if you
try if i had a room full of plaques and
like a pile full of money like no need
like uh ducktales
and i was just a rapper i would still
feel bad because you're not fulfilled
cause i was yeah it was exactly i would
just be disposable you know artists
based off of whatever song i was people
deemed was tight high at the time and
that would be you know and i would be
just chasing that